ينتقل الى الجانب الروسي حيث قال مجلس
الامن الروسي ان التدخل قال ان التدخل
الغرب في شؤون الداخليه لروسيا يزداد على
خلفيه العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا واكد
المجلس في بيانه ووجود رغبه لدى عدد من
الدول الاجنبيه في زعزعه استقرار الوضع
الاجتماعي
وكذلك في زعزعه الوضع السياسي في روسيا
بما في ذلك عن طريق تكثيف الانشطه غير
القانونيه على اساسي هياكل متطرف يمنيه
انا نايف وزير الخارجيه الرئيس
لا حوار مع واشنطن بخصوص اوكرانيا لان
المواقف تختلف بشكل جذري واكد نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ان النهج الامريكي لتصعيد
النزاع في اوكرانيا محفوظ بعواقب وخما حسب
تعبيرهم وبخصوص معاهده ستارت اللي هي الحد
من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه قال المسؤول
الروسي من الوضع في اوكرانيا حال دون
انعقاد اجتماع للجنه معاهده ستارت لان
واشرطه تصر على قضيه استئنافه التفتيش في
اطار ستار ستار
واشار نائب الوزير ان بلاده ستقترح على
الامريكيين بعد فتره مواعيد جديده لعقد
المشاورات ستارت
هذا مدير التنفيذي للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
فاتح بيرولا ان روسيا خسرت خسرت الى الابد
اوروبا كاكبر مشترك بل المشتري للطاقه
الروسيه اضافون انه ليس متاكدا فاذا كان
العالم بحاجه الى مزيد من النفط او منتجات
الفحم خلال سنوات الست او السبع القادمه